all right this is very negative all I
had to say is that I never said any
allegations I said it's a rather one or
the other it's either guilty or innocent
oh you think oh man based on the newest
evidence yes I actually was excited to
see ones on Twitch so you're excited by
the prospect of using me to make
yourself more money and get more views
that's okay he probably just burned a
bit don't give up on him I'm not giving
up on him and I don't think that I said
anything about Hans publicly that was
unfair so he's either the greatest chess
player that has ever lived or he's been
cheated what's crazy is he's doing all
of this for you
thank you
how do people how do people think that
like that this is insane
it's so fake how can you be such a thick
person
like their words speak for themselves